i've been watching you on your instagram
and that's how i keep tabs on you and
i've been watching this move into
professional wrestling you're you're now
in the wrestling world yeah it's so over
the top crazy like that i saw that clip
of you throwing that wrestler out of the
ring after you stun gun him in the ring
oh yeah that low down and dirty sami
zayn is that who you're talking about
howard that's exactly what i'm talking
about boy oh boy you taught him a lesson
man yeah who is the greatest wrestler
that ever lived beside yourself
now come on guys
be a little gracious who is the best
man i would say probably
my loved abdullah the butcher guerrilla
monsoon was a hell of a wrestler the
haystacks calhoun yeah
yeah the iron sheik too he was something
right yeah oh he was i mean he's amazing
on your show for all i mean i loved when
he was on your show
let me ask you something so you got
involved in this i assume
you said to yourself hey i got a movie
coming out what's a better place to
promote jackass than the wwe and so you
agreed to become quote-unquote a
wrestler right
well we were doing a promotion backstage
at the wwe
and
their head writer took me and jeff
tremaine out in the hall
and he's like you want to make a run for
the rumble
i was like
yeah yeah i'm like what what what what
what do you mean and he's like the royal
rumble i was like oh
yeah for sure and so then i've just been
you know training 24 7 howard and
flipping huge truck tires over the fence
the neighbors are so angry truck tires
weigh about the same as that pretty boy
austin theory
uh you don't even try to pretend that
you know like you just walk in the ring
and beat the [ __ ] out of these guys
and it's so funny i'm gonna walk in the
ring and make their life a living hell
howard are you having fun doing that or
do you sit there and go this is
ridiculous it's the most fun thing like
i wake up
every morning and i'm talking [ __ ] all
day long i spend a lot of my time on the
wwe instagram arguing with people it's
so fun
everybody brought out this child-like
thing in me of like the wrestling and
the fans get caught up in it i mean i
think they would say oh gee well you
know johnny's acting right now but no
they're caught up in this whole thing
johnny is not acting johnny is fully on
board johnny has left the building